okay for people who are joining this
livestream the topic today and people
who hear um the topic today is error
handling and code robusta fication
so this is primarily a project that
Christopher is doing to try to
understand but basically here's an
example of a goal take a random function
that has been submitted to the function
repository that does almost no error
checking what is the minimal path to
getting it to do decent quality error
checking what's you know you often you
have code where something goes wrong in
the middle of the code missing is
generated a failure object is generated
and the whole thing generates some pile
of symbolic garbage and goes crazy the
question is how can we do better and how
can we learn from sort of developments
in programming languages over recent
years to sort of invent a scheme that um
that's more promising and Christopher
has a thing when he sent me something
here but I can I can I mean I think the
my favorite current names for two of the
important constructs are enclose and
confirm but we can use God and contain
as well let me explain what I understand
the current concept to be so the issue
is let's say it's called confirm okay
the idea would be have confirm of exper
and if exper is a failure then that will
propagate to the nearest enclosing
enclose so this might be F of of
whatever some deeply nested thing right
um and then the result of this will be
that the enclose will get as soon as the
confirm is hit and as soon as the
confirm fails it will basically throw
out to the enclosing enclose and this
will then return the failure object Rep
presenting what happened inside that
confirm that a fair statement there
being closed well yeah I'm sure I mean
the basic idea is just that is just that
you you have a function that's in
similar to echo and that you can sort of
put it into code without significantly
changing its structure and the point of
that function is that it just checks
whether it's inputs or basically some
sort of failure and then they're
probably different versions of this that
detect different types of failures and
if it is a failure then it essentially
does something similar to throw and
catch and throws you up to the nearest
enclose I guess you can call it and
otherwise it just passes through like
echo and it doesn't change the course
evaluation and so the idea is that there
are various different forms of
confirmation that could be done there an
alternative name is guard there many
possible names but so an example of
confirmation would be did it generate a
message if it generated a message then
then fail out to the enclose if another
one would be what's this God evaluated
confirm the value yeah that one is guard
evaluated or confirm evaluated by far
the screwiest but that I think thinking
about how that could work as it is a
more complicated question right so the
idea here is that confirm evaluated
conceptually is did the thing evaluate
but let's see what are the other forms
of this there are what wouldn't that
sort of be just that its head is no
longer that it now has a different head
well right so what what the way that's
implemented right here is it basically
it's you know hold hold all complete
function and then it just checks I mean
it just checks it if if after you you
unhold it did it change right but
there's infinite screw eNOS like for
example let's say I have a pure function
and I like like something you can write
for example if you wrote a pure function
of you know guard evaluated of hash
amperes and and then you apply that pure
function to something
that will have different behavior than
if you run you know guard evaluated of
something right because it depends on it
will be evaluated before it gets
inserted into the confirm of the guard
or wherever it's called so there's a lot
of screwing us right I mean I would say
that in practice when when I want to
know if something is evaluated I check
that the head is no longer the head I
know I stuck in there right because if I
also had additional arguments right if I
do F of 2 + 2 and the result is F of 4
ensure it's changed but that's probably
not the result I wanted I probably
wanted whatever you know F to evaluate
to something you're you're giving a
heuristic for what I mean and by the way
the thing that one will realize as soon
as one gets deep into this is there are
many things where it will be somewhat
fury' sztyc and this question about did
it you know you're giving a heuristic
which we can then make precise by
there's a question from Sandra on the
live stream
how does this differ from throw and
catch well I think that the main I think
that the main difference between this is
their own catch would be that is that if
you want to use thrown catch for
essentially error handling you have to
significantly change the structure of
your code in that you know one of the
standard ways that people you know take
a function to make it give it better
error handling is you you know take your
code and then you basically write it in
a procedural way inside of a module or
something like that
with a bunch of variables and stuff and
then you just have if statements need to
say oh if it's broken then throw every
so often right and so this is basically
equivalent to that except that it means
that you would hopefully not have to
change the structure of your code that
much you don't have to like turn it into
this procedural thing so for example
let's do an example so let's say we say
god of I don't know whether one of us
this is God what can I use can I use you
use guard message probably or you could
use you can use guard patterns coming up
blue did you run the other notebook are
you sure you're going the same context
in the same kernel and the same up
Kayson I think so
is it this notebook got its own context
or something
no I am very confused here oh by the way
of course this implementation is you
know hacky in some ways I mean it's it's
calling throwing catch in some weird way
well it must have a different kernel why
and just press you know command and the
bat selected so you know that it's not a
difference I could version okay weird oh
did you try running it maybe it's just
the syntax highlighting is broken I
didn't try rolling out oh nothing okay
so I'll runs in the snow book it's very
weird okay so here um okay
Oh somebody is making a bunch of
background noise um so let's just see
what happens if I just say guard of five
it says okay fives okay so but if I say
guard of missing it'll say okay big mess
that should be better but yes okay so
then I if I say contain goddamn missing
then I'll just get a failure object
right good so I mean basically if it's
if there's an error it propagates the
error up to the contain or Dean close
but so if I say God can I map God over a
list you could yes so in this case here
it's a normal guard doesn't have any
weird attributes some of the other
guards do like I think guard message has
like is like hold to hold first or
something like that right so the idea
here is if anything is screwy if
anything is if if the direct contents of
a confirm or a guard are missing then
the thing throws
the outer enclose of containing or
whatever it is so people understand what
we're saying here yes so in the
beginning and what is it that it guards
against messages know that there are
different forms of confirm confirm is a
slightly preferred name here so confirm
or God on the the initial version that
just the thing on its own all it does is
to say is what contained in here a
failure object or a well I mean more
generally right so it's a presumably
something like missing cue or failure
cue yes failure to you exactly exactly
so so there right now in this notebook
here they're I think five different
guard four or five different guards so
there's guard test which which checks
whether it's basically like assert you
give it a function and it checks if that
function returns true but it's a turn
yeah specific values you know so failure
and missing no no case that's the desert
god there's several different functions
so there's one of them is called guard
test right which is different from just
playing guard and guard test you give it
a second argument which is a function
which it checks against can i curry are
like this right now no yeah you probably
should be able to but okay yeah that's
fine
and there's also similarly there's guard
pattern which is the analogous thing but
for patterns and so on so plain old
guard I see so this is a predicate
pattern and then there's a hard-wired
failure yes you can use valuate question
mark guard store
there you go oh god it is another thing
which we're talking now that's that's a
yeah more complicated thing did that
drive when I said also card failure
would you do cause around failure is
that if there is a message yes yes I
have 15 claims in attending the most
thing right it's is it'll be common that
you want to do messages and failures so
we should have a single writes only one
one thing is you have to double well I
mean right what exactly so I mean one
question is for example the default
guard you know the the default one could
also look for messages right now I think
the factoring of exactly what um you
know which of you know what exactly the
heuristic should be for each one of
these and how exactly this collection
should be factored is not clear yet and
needs input but you know the first the
first issue is the whole framework here
so the whole framework says guard
detects one of these it jumps you out to
a contain that's correct
okay does it have tags like catch and
throw it probably should it absolutely
should
otherwise you'll run into issues where
you write a function using garden
contain or and it takes input that
somebody you know provides their own
thing that is has its own guard and they
have their contain outside of your
function and then things you know get
caught at the wrong level yeah yeah that
would be that would be bad I mean it
would be nice if the code assistance
system for example this person ibly it's
contain level you can decide to take
action and do something to recover
exactly yes yeah so you can so there's
right now the way it works is there's a
second argument you could supply to
contain which is a pure function which
essentially is given a failure object
which contains you know certain
information about what was inside the
that failed and then it can try and you
know by default it's just identity and
so it returns the failure object but you
know you can have other things so
there's an example here for example
where the contain is inside of a select
and it will always return false if the
guard fails implementational you sit
done with catch and throw er yeah right
now it is I mean the implementation is
is not real okay yeah it's it's a
prototype yeah right I would I mean I'm
not sure they're having a general
function as the second argument really
addresses the need for tags and I just
want to voice that if we do have tags
which we probably should we should not
repeat the mistake of throw and catch
that there isn't a thing that will catch
all of them right one args run catch are
fundamentally orthogonal to to args like
I mean right let me ask this question
whether there are some other things too
that they're very old like check and so
on isn't there like a whole check family
like a guard family yeah host family
no okay there's no mention check is
fundamentally broken because it it runs
the entire computation and only does the
thing with check after it's done if the
message happened to show up so it
doesn't it doesn't actually abort
anything in repository that's related to
this as well yeah say this is the
ultimate sign that you survive trouble
your function when they're I think not
one to I think there's three different
versions of check in the function
repository that are like the check and
if it fails throw immediately instead of
waiting to finish yeah right and check
out check always and documented I mean
it's it's what is it you've seen it
before it basically can consume all sort
of all sorts of supports nah not just
sort of messages
to throw it so it's check its check and
it's check abort together and more yeah
those those check return and check
metric in the function president we also
have throw failure and catch failure
which work is a pair to do a very
similar thing and fail on message which
is similar to check but it stops on the
first message and it yeah and
Christopher's absolutely right that this
is a sign that what we have built in is
lacking right so let's talk about these
tags so Christopher have you sort of
digested what these things are trying to
do in function repository this it could
be that they are on to some in a piece
of it too yeah yeah yeah I haven't I
haven't I hadn't heard of the throw
failure and catch failure so I should
look at those but I've looked at for
example the different things for dealing
with messages and so on yeah I mean the
friction repositories all top level
stuff so it's yeah it's probably yeah
but there's still an indication you know
I think that their example should show
why they wrote it right so presumably
yeah yeah and that's that's their sort
of use case basically yeah absolutely
yeah okay so so let's talk about tags
for a minute because as you're writing
this code and you write a confirm and
and enclose or whatever that the thing
is going to be called the gardener
contain the you know you know I'm
putting this enclosed to catch this
collection of guards
right you know that at the time when
you're you know writing a the you know
what when you're writing your code but
that's not visible in the actual thing
this is there's something you need to
and I was thinking if I'm gonna rake the
recovery mechanism contain something
what come what do I know what do I get
when it sort of throws you
got to throw some information or have no
recourse to command a recover do I know
throwing a failure object that has a
bunch of information inside it's not
clear where it is it's all baked in
there yeah the only thing is so it's
it's sort of complicated though because
there's some like you know guard tests
where it's kind of obvious where it
should I mean so all the guards
presumably in part of the package that
they throw should contain the expression
you know the held form the expression
that inside of them probably but then
there other questions like for example
if it's a you know if it's a guard test
there's other obvious stuff that you
might show but if it's like a message
then there isn't as much yeah you can't
like if it's a guard test you can well
yeah I don't know I mean I think that
there are some depending on the type of
guard there might be different
information that you have to throw but
but but in general there will be some
association inside the failure object
that you could unpack but including the
failure object should say what type of
god failure caused that to be propagated
up yes yes and I mean in principle you
can unpack it and see what happens
but right here's the question that I'm
asking that you're writing a piece of
code you write a confirm you write an
enclose you know when you're writing
that code that the confirming the
enclose is supposed to be paired right
now you could invent some arbitrary
weird tab or dos just new names for what
we're talking about yes yes sir two
alternative names I don't know which one
is better but but um and you know I
don't know Chris when I talked a little
bit about names but but people have
ideas for names that would be I mean
we've got a long list of possible things
and there's a goal to have the the name
for something like god be comparatively
short so that like echo you can okay the
typical piece of code right when this is
implemented the typical piece of code
that you'll see in the function
repository will start enclosed blah blah
blah blah and there'll be it'll be all
sorts of little confirms inside it and
so those names have to be things that
aren't too weird
in you see what I'm saying cuz cuz a lot
of code you know sort of
reinforcing code will consistent
spraying these these names and all sorts
of places um so the question I mean I'm
wondering is sort of how this makes code
cleaner how do we do it today we
basically do error checking locally you
do a step and then you sort of inspect
and do something then you decide to move
on
rather procedurally usually yes problems
pretty much right so the goal here is
you know confirm the step you just took
if something went wrong this is how you
enclose that you know this is the
enclosure that you have been thrown to
but again let's let's ask people here
because this is why we wanted this
collection of people you know there is
there are patterns for error checking
that have been developed many different
ones what do people have to say about
how they do it I mean is it in fact
correct I mean I think Christopher
wanted to actually look at examples of
error checking code and I don't know
whether you've done that Christopher
already um yeah I hope people do this
well typically I mean I'll just speak
for myself
this is Rob I typically use throwing
catch and and always when our co and our
you know in system code I always use a
tag ID or what is it
it's a string I just use a string so
ization we have an optimisation
exception that we use it's just
something not to interfere with anything
a user might do right I mean although in
principle right I mean a user could a
user if user had written throw of
optimization exception or something like
that it would they would conflict it's
just unlikely that they would do that
yes it's unlikely they would do that so
I think we have to take as an axiom
you know it's probably got to be you you
IDs and we just have to take it no so
the thing is is you know speaking from
the visualization code there's one tag
it's used you know sort of globally
throughout all the visualization code
and and so I mean because you have the
catch which is you know wrapped around
at a very high level and if it triggers
the catch then you know bar chart or
whatever is gonna return on evaluated
but all the like individual little
utility functions that are shared across
bar chart and pie chart and list plot
and whatever all have the ability to do
the throw and so it's a very general tag
which I suppose it could still be a UUID
but but then the code becomes impossible
to read and it's you know forty digits
long and there's no guarantee that you
your ideas are unique either it's just
unlikely that they will clash right so
we do the same thing an optimization is
Brett described we have we have you know
bunches of little throw functions that
can throw the same thing and then we
have caches at different levels
depending on you know what you actually
want to do and so when you unroll after
you after you catch what do you
typically do first we'll do how much of
the payload do you inspect when you
catch and then what do you typically do
to recover almost nothing I mean most of
the time if it gets to the catch the
catch is at a high enough level that
it's essentially you gave bar chart bad
enough input or option settings or
something that all we can do is return
and evaluate it the other is fallback to
some default value and again in which
case you aren't looking at the payload
at all you're just saying this didn't
work I'm going to fall back to something
that I know does work is slightly
different so what I do I have several
different tags this helps me in in
keeping track of modularity
depends on what and then the other thing
I always do systematically is that right
before each throw there is always a
message explaining why we are stopping
there and what I throw is always done or
failed and then functions that no
dysfunction
I'm calling could return to our fail
they will check whether this function
the way is so this is where you're
saying that if you have some if you have
some big function that's like the
user-visible function instead of just
having one catch basically at the top of
that you have caches that are lower down
and then if you're bigger function calls
the smaller function and the smaller
function return dollar failed then it
will handle that failure at multiple
levels is that kind of what you're
saying yes because in that way I can use
my own functions right yeah I yes I mean
I am sort of in take it even a step
further than Jose I I never have
non-local throws and catches all of my
throws are lexically within their catch
because I just I've seen one too many
Java stack trace and and so I just
believe I don't believe in non-local
throws and catches there's also other
code that we have like our symbolic code
where they are always poly algorithmic
and it's frequent that a solver actually
fails and that's not a dramatic thing
you you can't you can't often predict
beforehand whether it's gonna succeed or
fail so it's sort of built into its
mechanism that it will fail you know it
will try something and fail and that's
just how it operates and obviously you
don't fail the whole big function
because one local out of a hundred
solvers fail you right well we have that
we have that numerical computation as
well you know if some method fails it
doesn't mean it's completely hopeless so
you may want to go on and try in fact I
just mentioned as a part of this
discussion that an optimization we
introduced sort of an intermediate thing
which I called it's it's a you know it's
it's not a system set
it's a it's an optimization symbol
called partial success and that's when
the miracle method gets a solution but
it's not really to the to the accuracy
or precision that was requested by the
user that's interesting so I mean just
one one point to make maybe so so a few
things so the first thing is there's a
question about you know how far out do
you put then close your container
whatever we're calling it right now so I
mean I think for one thing I think that
in general you know the general pattern
that you're doing you're not necessarily
throwing all the way to top you don't
throw and catch right presumably this is
basically just you know it's it's
multi-level error propagation but where
the number of levels could be any number
right so you you know you can propagate
different different depths then the
other thing is that right I mean there's
the question of I mean I think there's
sort of a a like good practice question
about where do you put the container the
catch right like I mean I was I was
talking to someone about this the other
day you know we were sort of right like
like I think I was talking to Conor
about this about how you know maybe a
more puritanical version of this would
be something that did something like
return where it forces it to be in the
same function I mean return is a crazy
symbol so it shouldn't be but you know
right so so in principle you might say
they good practice would be that you you
always have you know the contain
lexically around the confirm and so on
but but this this raises the question of
dynamic versus lexical that is we could
and this relates also to the tags
question you know there is a version of
this that could be I don't know exactly
how it would work but one could imagine
a lexical version the statement that um
or maybe one couldn't I don't know I
mean that that will be you know within
one function it could be lexical well
but then the thing is is that like I
maybe I don't actually know what return
does if you don't run it in a function
but so maybe it already does this but I
feel like I feel like the behavior
shouldn't be that different depending on
whether you put it in function versus
whether you
put it in some you know random piece of
code right like it especially because
you might just be running it in in code
where you're not writing any functions
right if you're just running a no sure
you're running something in a notebook
interactively you don't want to have to
package things up and functions in order
to tell it no but the question the
question is is it lexical if it was
lexical there would be no issue with
tags I claim maybe I'm not but um if its
lexical then I mean it's not as powerful
as the dynamic version because in the
dynamic version something deep inside
some other piece of code might generate
a throat you might generate a confirm
failure and then propagate up if its
lexical it's much safer because you can
explicitly see you know my question is
people's use of these constructs are
they in fact using them lexically or are
they using them in some much deeper
function that is I've definitely found
the need to propagate things outwards I
just made a resource function recently
called nested catch which sort of
addresses that issue what does it do
it's it's like catch but it'll propagate
the throw upwards to the outermost
enclosing nested catch so if you're
writing you know package functions and
you have an error in one of your private
functions you can throw that error all
the way to the top of your package and
still have your caches enclosing your
stuff lexically so you can use your
private functions that they would learn
about uncut throw throws and stuff like
that C C to me I mean I think this area
is fairly important and and having
multiple types of functions is not
completely crazy it seems to me I mean
just like we have module and we have
block which do lexical versus dynamic
scoping I could imagine that there is a
lexical version of this which is much
safer and much more what one would use
in production code and there is a
dynamic version that is much more you
know is usually not worn used in
production code but nevertheless I mean
because in production code if it was
lexical and there was a good forwarding
mechanism for encloses
that might be a nice robust way to do it
perhaps I don't know so so okay there
are two questions so the first question
is if it's if its lexical so so if its
lexical then presumably okay so if its
lexical first of all would you want to
include being closed or will you just
say oh it just goes to the top of the
function or something like that no no
you want some what you want to include
the enclose because okay because that's
the I mean in a piece of code maybe it's
crazy to have it lexical I don't
understand the propagation of right so
so right so so my catch is that my catch
is almost never it right I suppose I
might return or I'm you know if for some
reason they need to return on evaluate
it right then I'm going to have you know
res slash semi res not equal dollar
failed or something by the way that
whole returning unev Ally waited we have
to get a better better way of doing that
we had a mechanism in version 0.9 which
was taken out at the last minute because
it was semantically hard to define but I
really think we need a better you know
rather than these weird you know idioms
we need a better way to just say return
an evaluated did you think about that
Christopher yet this we talked about it
a bit but we haven't really I don't
think we've had any real conclusions I
mean there's also just the general
problem which we mentioned earlier about
detecting when things are turn on
evaluated right and you can do things
like you know right like was proposed
earlier you can just look at the head is
what you expect it is but it's kind of
like there isn't you know when a
function returns an evaluated it's sort
of it's sort of ambiguous what that
means like whether that means oh I'm
just a symbolic function and I'm happily
returning that evaluated or if it means
I've horribly failed and my inputs are
terrible and right a good example of
that the head failing is is sparse array
I mean that's that's not a good check
for sparse array what do you mean well
if you construct a sparse array with
rules it creates an object which has
head sparse array as well but it's
completely different inside I think the
non valid sparse array
yeah so anything that's its own
constructors and write anything so
constructor that that cannot work for
also mention that the lexical I mean I
it the lexical I think so one place
where we use where I've used throws and
this would actually be a very nice
mechanism for is is in in various
frameworks we've put together such as
you know the structured array framework
that Jose is used we have a you know a
particular throw tag you can throw out
to say okay I don't have an algorithm
for this so just go back to the normal
thing and you don't know where it's
gonna be caught it's it's something that
you know sort of a person writing code
for this would do insula lexical would
be completely inadequate for that but
this guard you know non lexically could
be really useful for that right there
are a few comments on our live stream I
just want to mention them as a comment
from gecko state talking about failure
apparently a library foreclosure
Christopher might be worth looking at um
anybody know about that here um as
comments about try let's see to choose
saying use null objects instead of
control structures for handling error
handling in Java Java use finally to
execute code regardless um let's see
various comments about Java API s yeah
there's a good there's a there's a good
comment from well I can't pronounce wsh
about monads so I mean this is a okay so
there's maybe just something we should
mention quickly this is another there's
another version of this which I think
has uses but but different uses which is
basically the problem of single level
error propagation so that is basically
the idiom you know if missing Q of hash
then hash otherwise F of hash right so
this is like really common for example
if you're doing like data processing
stuff and maybe you have a list with a
bunch of data in and some of them are
missing and you want to run some
function over it and of course if the if
the value is missing you just want to
propagate the
up one level and if it's not missing you
want to apply the function and of course
it could be more general than missing it
can be failure and stuff like that but
you know right I mean this is a very
common idiom so this is this is another
thing that should probably exists
although should probably be some sort of
headdress or something so is that what
you've had got it is that where you're
guarded does
um I think garden is slightly different
garden your garden here is kind of crazy
I think guarded basically yeah it just
it just basically runs guard on all of
the inputs with the theory just being
it's a headdress version but I think
it's I don't think it's that useful I
mean but the use of it would be
functions that take functions that take
pure functions like if you wanted to
basically use guard on the inputs to you
know nest or something like that then
yeah but so the other thing is I don't
know what the right name for it is we
don't have any idea yet but this the
basic idea is if this has any argument
that is missing then it becomes missing
otherwise it will otherwise the thing
would just return f of X Y right that's
the other form so that is a that is a
non propagating and I suspect there's
something in between these two that is
this is a one level non propagating you
know non double error propagation right
one level yeah right whereas this is I
mean there's two paradigms there's the
single level and then there's the throw
catch type paradigm well there's
actually two kinds of throw catch
there's lexical throw catch and dynamic
throw catch this is in some sense a
lexical one level propagation is that
true I would argue it's not lexical but
I mean I think that right I'm not even
sure it's one level right it why is that
right because this it's well no I'm
saying it may be fewer than one levels
right I mean I don't see how this you
know aborts the rest of the evaluation
it doesn't it doesn't this is the point
is right so if it aborted the whole
evaluation that would
many levels because they could be very
deep in it no no no no I mean right so
in in sort of the idiom that you know I
was talking about right I have an outer
catch and then that very you know
various points I will throw failure if
something goes wrong right that to me is
one level i how do i accomplish this
with accomplish that with maybe i don't
see me looks like less than one level I
think we're using different terminology
I mean so the point about this this is
this is like this is a c'mon ad so I
mean this is like the maybe monad in
Haskell for exam okay I don't know what
that is okay okay that's fine
I mean basically it's just what this is
doing okay well I'm saying one level
what I mean is that an error occurred at
you know level three levels deep in your
code and it's been propagated up so now
it's at two levels deep if that makes
any sense right so the point is that
instead of the error you know happening
deep in your code and going all the way
up to the top that's the use for certain
garden contain and there's a separate
use case a separate or there's a
separate problem that a separate
function should solve which is the
single level error propagation problem
which is more like let's say I've data
with missing in it I want to map some
function over it and my function can't
take missing right so these are two
different two distinct problems so this
is essentially I mean one part of this
is the handling of missing in lots of
functions is quite problematic I mean
something like mean does not handle
missing in any very sensible way but
this is dealing with a even an upstream
question which is I've got you know I've
got some data look if I say data two
three four five missing six seven and I
square it okay I get a totally stupid
result right
whereas if what I did here instead and
I'm afraid it's not very elegant but if
I said you know maybe hash squared of
this slash out that
/ shut well is it the maybe you could
talk about we could talk about having
level specs or something but I think
this is the / that is maybe there
okay so then / at this then the result
will not be missing squared it will just
be missing in that position right it'll
be it'll be 4 9 16 25 missing 36 49 etc
that make sense to people but let's also
say I was muted I was asking a question
of is is that is that real result
because there may be always return to
missing or because it returned it turns
into identity if something goes wrong I
think it turns into identity because I
think that there might be useful
information and missing like a failure
object might have an actual packaging
inside it well missing could have
packaging inside it right I mean but
that's another difference between these
by the ways that I think for for the
confirm and closed version you'd want to
package in a failure object by default
but because basically you know let's say
you have some confirmed test and it's
testing for something weird like let's
say you you a URL request and you're
requesting you're testing the status
code is what you expected right then if
that gets propagated up as a HTTP
request object then then this is like a
weird thing to be directly propagated up
I think of failure is easier to handle
at higher levels and if you want you can
unpack it but in this case if it's just
a single level you just want to move the
failure up you know upper level let's
let's do a couple of things here first
of all maybe Christopher or others could
review stuff in other languages and
other ideas and then let's talk some
more so that was really my question to
you know like some mmm some other sort
of more recent language designs of how
they tackle it like Julia for instance
or Python I guess is not that modern but
they certainly have a variety of code
going in there Christopher yeah yeah I
want to talk about this alright so I can
I can say if you can I I don't know much
about Julia but I would say that there
are in most the modern language that
I've seen that have sort of tried to
seriously do err
handlings like for example in in swift
or rust which I think both care a lot
about this the basic strategy is they
have two constructs so in rust or in
Swift of these things called optionals
which is basically if I have an int you
know if I have a type int I can also
have a thing that's of type int question
mark which is an optional version of int
where can either have a value like two
or it can be nil and then the idea is
you have functions which are basically
equivalent to this maybe thing it's a
sort of a Mon a DA Parader
idea and I have a function where if I if
I have a function let's say I have a
function f and it takes an int then I
can make a version of that function I
think you just write f question mark and
that would turn F question mark is a
function that takes an int question mark
and returns a whatever f returned
question mark and basically does what
maybe does here so if the input was nil
it returns nil if it wasn't nil it
returns out of that value and then the
other the other type of error handling
they have which i think is kind of not
as elegant but it's sort of analogous to
what this enclose and confirm does is
they have like try and I think it's
trying to accept or try and catch and
and that's sort of right you have things
that throw exceptions and it goes all
the way up to the catch which is some
catch block but it's like the long
distance jump right that's the long
distance jump version and then the
optional is the short distance there
like maybe here hmm yeah and I mean Russ
does something pretty similar like they
have this um the Conner can probably
talk more about this that they have like
these I'm result objects and these I
think called option objects which are
analogous to the pretty much analogous
to optionals and Swift yeah Connor do
you want to say about and then the issue
that the the question I mean rest also
has a question mark operator and it you
know you apply it at the end of an
expression so you do you know expert
question mark and if the result you know
is a failure or you know some missing
like thing then it gets propagated and
returns from the current function
and how did these languages handle what
we've been discussing as tags for
confirming clothes well I mean in the
case of so I mean of course for the case
of like optionals or option and rust
these are single levels so you don't
have to worry about that for for in the
case of like the question Rock Connor
was just talking about I'm pretty sure
question mark you can only write
question mark inside of a function where
the whole function returns an option
type right right so so it basically if
the question fails it just calls return
yeah and goes all the way to the top of
the function and then in contrast with
Swift you have to have these I think
they're called cache blocks where it's
you know you write catch open brace some
code close brace and then after the
catch you write accept and then you
write the name of the exception or
something like that and then under there
you write the code that you run if the
exception is you know if the exception
is triggered which is almost exactly
analogous actually to the way that
confirming and closes here so Sanders
commenting in Python there's assert
raised and then try X except else and
finally what is that what is the finally
what is the notion of cleanup for what
we're talking about here in other words
if if you had constructed something then
you had to confirm the confirmed fails
but you've got some open file or
something or do we not what kind of
cleanup and there's a question to
everybody here about you know cleanup I
mean there are very they're fairly few
long distant side-effects the main ones
I think have to do with files what do we
you know how do we do long distance
cleanup how do people handle at an
existing code is it mostly stateless I
usually is with local settings and the
internal context for that we have a
pretty good mechanism for handling that
type of stuff what does that do it
basically the last argument of it like
if you throw over deferred the first and
it takes three arguments and evaluates
them in order and the first and last are
uninterruptible
oh right so the burst is is basically
saying I'm gonna open a stream or
something like that and the last is I'm
gonna close the stream and in the middle
even if something goes wrong it'll still
close the stream yes
if you throw from expert there it will
finish final before actually sending
that that throw so you can clean up your
streams or whatever we should have this
function as a user level function y know
how long we had check abort - how long
have we had this function with local
settings I vaguely remember that
function for a very very long time ago
is that there was some that was
preventing us I don't but it's been here
for at least as long as I've been with
the company so that's a decade grad and
try some bug that we wanted to fix
before we documented it I don't know /
remember Jeremy might if who I don't
think is in this meeting might remember
the details I don't know what the status
of that is
but this seems like a highly useful
construct and passed possibly was a
better name than with local settings
much right I mean is there a value is
that the right construct for this that
this is always a block I mean it'll be
it's some kind of block basically so so
so I mean there's a to reference another
another reader language so in go there
was a you know in there go has very
little like actual air handling
constructs because they sort of want to
be minimalist but there was a proposal
for a go to about how to do error
handling and situations like this and
they have a similar but slightly weirder
concept which is that you know
throughout your code you can sort of
write a you can write a line that
basically says you know run this at the
end and if the function fails then it
will go up it'll it'll go up and run
those lines in Reverse
if that makes sense so basically if I
you write open this file oh and at the
end right close it and so on or like it
this thing basically you're sewing final
you're sewing something to do in the
final state and those and when does that
so go out of context so to speak when
that block has been finished then the
sews that then the so finals that were
in that block are no longer valid is
that the idea I guess I'm not sure what
you mean by so final I mean what I mean
is you're just drawing things out there
and you're saying if this block were to
not execute were to not end itself
naturally then go back and reap all the
things that were sown and evaluate them
well kind of but in in reverse order
which I guess by the way this is this is
I'm realizing that this is this is very
nicely done with this with local
settings because if you have nested with
local settings presumably it runs them
from the inner one to the outer one yes
so it sort of mimics this reverse order
concept okay so let's talk about other
people's experience with error handling
and I think the other the other thing
we've talked about a little bit is
messages and how devastating a message
is and trying to bucket different
categories of errors and to you know was
this just a weak error like you're this
particular numerical method didn't
converge to and you know I've long been
advocating the idea that we have
messages that are off by default that
represent things you might not that you
might consider an error although you
might consider them just par for the
course like that you know that logarithm
turned out to make a complex number or
something you might consider that an
error or you might consider that just
par for the course you want it Chris why
did you do you want to comment on this
question about bucketing error messages
I mean I'm not sure how much there's the
same it's just that the thing is an
existing code messages can mean like
vastly different things all right then
the fact that a message the fact that
some message was thrown doesn't
necessarily tell you much because
you know like in a case of part right I
met when part throws a message saying
you know the index is out of range this
is like a catastrophic you know failure
I mean the whole function is toast
but you know when integrate there was a
message half the time it's just you know
pseudonym numerical thing and and you
don't you don't really care and it's
gonna it's gonna return reasonable
result anyway and so right I mean this
is this is the problem with some
functions like guard message and stuff
like that is that you know you might
think that messages or messages tell you
if it's failed but message is actually
the fact that some messages thrown
doesn't actually really tell you
anything officially so right and and and
I mean right and another problem is if
it only triggers on messages that
actually fire if you somehow got into a
state where general stop has been
invoked then it won't actually fire and
on the other hand if it responds to all
messages even quieted one you know
there's such an infinite number of
messages that are off by default that
you know you won't be able to evaluate
anything right right but the question is
how do you is there a meaningful way to
Buckett messages so on our live stream
Brian is saying you know differentiate
between info warning error and fatal I
think that's really challenging for us
but I don't know whether those I mean
that's a that's a message categories you
know do we have a meaningful it turns
out we actually have some documentation
that does distinguish message types we
didn't we find that recently it's like
message groups or something like yeah
I've mentioned these before in these
meetings right Maxine for v-6 I think
you know but they're sort of functional
areas they're not severity levels okay
certainly the packing the group is used
a lot on and off of packing what do you
mean I see what's on backing that this
is it's it's a group of messages Oh
death group okay I thought you meant a
group of people
from I have a comment here messages
something that we have imposed on us is
the fact that when I'm function emits a
message it has to have the right head it
has to come from that function and when
you have nested function sometimes it's
quite difficult to keep track of that so
we go into considerable effort to keep
track of the right head to meet the
message and I wonder how important is
that well it's the only way is go ahead
I just can't clarify so so what you mean
it's like let's say you have some
internal function you know in like
Geographics or something that's called
by a whole bunch of different top-level
functions and the point is is but but
that inner function might throw a
message and you want it so that the head
on that message matches the top level
function these are called as opposed to
the tiny internal one or even a more
dramatic example suppose you call solve
which loves to issue messages is it okay
to see the solved message and you know
certainly QA complains if you know if e
ties wonderful function issues a solve
message so I need to sort of catch that
and then we throw it backs optimization
stuff which is relatively new is we we
trap the messages and then then attach
the the outer solver head to to all the
messages that seem appropriate because
this has an unfortunate consequence
which is that we have a limit in the
number of messages per function and so
because different functions will start
emitting different messages we have this
view of messages yeah and so if we had
some sort of global limit or the
messages were not associated to heads
then we would have just a few messages
and that's all you already have the
information that something is going on
so by the way I mean as a general point
about this arguably what you'd like to
do is instead of having some you know
some random function that you're calling
deep in your code throw a message and
then you sort of cache that and handle
it and so on what you might like to do
is something like you know what guard
message kind of does which is the run
guard message around the code that might
throw a message
and then and then at the top you know
you haven't enclosed that can then see
Oh a message was thrown you know here's
the message let me deal with this and so
on which it seems like like Rob it
seemed like what you were saying was
sort of similar to that in the comments
when does it happen right does does the
message get generated if the function is
gonna take a minute to run it makes a
big difference whether it is generated
well I guess if if the guard fails it's
propagating to being closed anyway
so there is no time delay yeah I mean it
shouldn't do it check does which is
finish the evaluation before you're
wrong right but but this question I mean
the whole point about attaching symbol
names to messages is that is one way in
which messages become computable the
names of the messages are absolutely not
computable but the you know the head of
the function which generated the message
you might think you could compute with
does anybody compute with that or not or
did you mean the whole message name like
do you mean having colon colon etc or I
mean something like log colon colon odd
count or something like this which is
the fact that there is a meaningful
computable thing there I'm asking the
question does anybody in there code as
they generate messages somewhere does
anybody look at that head to make a
decision about what to do with the
message or does nobody care and as this
thing could be that's what checkers but
people do that deal check-in what that's
the place that's the place where you
name a message if you wanna catch no I
understand but then you're naming the
whole message or not just naming the the
head are you know but you're naming the
whole message name but that's one place
where it's sort of a computable use of a
message head of a message name right I
understand that but what I'm asking is
the fact that that first thing is the
name of a function and you could
potentially look for that function is
that relevant or is the whole thing here
could it be message ID number
such-and-such and that would be good
enough I mean or or alternatively just
you know org CT as opposed to log colon
arc CT is that what you're saying yes it
is incredible
oh I mean so when you're debugging if
you if I'm debugging a case of you know
Wolfram code I look for basically the
first message that comes out in the head
and that gives me an idea of where it's
happening well if you didn't know the
head of the function where it happened
if you just instead of like a transpose
message you just had some random message
you wouldn't have any idea that was
happening and transpose and where would
you how could you even start to look so
basically what you're saying is that
it's it's a good way of characterizing
you know you have a big piece of code
and there might be eight transposes in
your code right just knowing that it's
transposed as opposed to linear solve or
something is it it is it is a kind of a
you know a trick for somewhat localizing
where the message came right so it's not
it's not computable except within my
head basically that's what I'm trying to
say but I mean the stacktrace would give
you a little bit more information about
where the message you know where in your
code the message came from I mean right
and the debugger you know when it was in
operation so to speak would potentially
actually display for you and I don't
know whether I mean there's Brenton have
any comments on on this and the whole
question about connecting messages to
code and so on I mean this is there were
patterns to check you know I can
definitely the system I have can
definitely check for these patterns of
usage and you know no I guess my
question is you know the best case would
be you click on a message you know if I
generate a message somewhere here if I
say um let's say um one over zero right
well certainly the length depends on the
head right which link the the
documentation link yeah right so if
there's a speed of message page it'll go
to the message page but if it doesn't it
will go to the head yeah I think the
head is important because half the time
I mean I don't know half the time I
don't even look at the message I just
see oh it's a problem with you know part
I know what the problem is
right but okay but but but so the
question they re yeah go ahead no I mean
the one I mean the names of messages by
the way let's talk a little bit about
that you know the names of messages were
intended to be short but not completely
incomprehensible back in version one I
suspect that if we plotted the length of
the names of messages over time they
will have gotten progressively longer
does anybody want to comment on that
there are some very long message names
these days I mean you can see that
they're not even displayed in the latest
you know I know we display the message
names because they were kind of a mess
it's only on tooltip right right this is
kind of frustrating to me but well no
you okay
yes but now I need to move my hand from
the keyboard to the mouse or trackpad
and hover and wait in order to see
something that used to be just right
there I mean I think that I think in
principle the problem is that I mean
there are a lot of there are a lot of
functions that have really ugly message
names right right there's a question
should we curate the message names in
some way and if so what would they be
curated to because the problem one of
the worst problems of the message name
is you have a very meaningful message
name and the meaning is wrong that is
the message says you know
ill-conditioned system of equations but
actually the reason for the numerical
error was something completely different
and you're off being confused I mean
that seems like that's more general I
mean do you mean where the message name
says that but then the message content
explains the correct thing or do you
mean where the whole message is just
straight up wrong well with oxygen this
is the famous thing about you know the
comments and code and more bugging than
the code so to speak and they get people
confused because knowing what went right
I mean our messages back from the very
beginning you know we the messages are
close to always just say what happened
they're not supposed to offer a theory
but increasingly our messages do offer a
theory you know so it might say you know
file not found or something or it might
say know what I did say it might say you
know um somebody's making a much better
um no I mean they're trying to offer it
some of them are starting to offer
advice the following went wrong
try these tried no right there's a
question about how that should work and
whether that should be segmented off
from the just say what happened because
the problem with offering advice is that
it might be completely wrong
that is the thing can somebody give an
example of this there's got to be a
obvious example here but you should be
able to give an example
well yeah an example an example I've
it's one I've seen you comment on is the
some of the messages that come out of a
compiler you know if you give a function
it doesn't recognize it it gives a bunch
of suggestions which are almost always
wrong stupid Steve I was thinking more
of something like indie solve or convex
optimization where at least some
fraction of the time the message is
right try method blah or try you know
where at least some fraction of the time
actually does tell you something useful
well those that that's that's fine but
the thing that concerns me is the case
where no what we know is that things
went way out of control somewhere inside
the code but we think that the chances
are that happened because of whatever
and we just say that but it turns out in
reality it happened because of something
else and the person finds it much harder
to debug because they were just led off
track
now hopefully Brenton's stuff with code
assistance will give on a better way to
handle things like that where you can I
mean I think the both standard sort of
tell what happened and you have advice
um there's often sort of extra state
that needs to set up in computation just
to sort of
and tell what happened you know in a
reasonable way back to the user anyways
for advice there's additional state than
something that needs to be set up in
order to kind of arrive at that well an
example of an advisory thing that Utah
was looking for is is we did this all a
little while ago that if so in our
optimization solvers now if somebody
gives it if if if you wind up with a
constraint that's just strictly true it
gives a warning message because so often
it was the case that you put in a
constraint wrong or you used an equal or
something like that instead of an actual
constraint and it you know if it's true
of course it's true but it's not
typically what the user intended okay so
I think that's an incorrectly done thing
so I think that should go through
Brenton's code assistance stuff
lexically look at what the person typed
in and in other words if it turned out
somewhere inside the code that the thing
turned into true but it was not
obviously and you know and I'm trivially
true because of something that they you
know typed a single legal instead of
double equals or something right you
know and the single equals should turn
red inside the inside the optimization
code as it does inside solved yes no
that I mean having having an extra extra
purse or pass or something for things
like this we'd actually have access to
would be would be incredibly I think
that's basically what Brenton is
building yeah it's elaborate I mean and
you know we have to distinguish stuff
that can be done at code construction
time there's the stuff that can only be
done at run time and what Brenton is
building is an elaborate system for
dealing with code construction time is
that a fair characterization Brenton
yeah I mean traditionally we say static
analysis and stuff like that but yeah
the lexical I mean yes what you're
saying is true right yeah there's a
different issue which I mean when we're
talking about messages that's all run
time and but but I want to come back to
yes um some is asking here about where
is our message documentation these days
I was looking for it recently and I
couldn't find it where is
you have to generate the message and
link it and follow the link and it's not
browsable is that what you're saying
basically why isn't it why isn't there a
big why isn't there I assess Brian or
somebody who's responsible for
documentation why does that not go to
the message oh because there is no
message page for it so so do something
like the following you'd said dollar II
what is it doc sorry dollar notebook in
line storage limits zero that's probably
gonna break my whole session but yeah
okay no no won't and now do like sparse
array of one two three okay now copy
that output then evaluate it and then
input cell this is pretty elaborate okay
and oh why is turn that should take you
to an actual message page my gosh that
was really elaborate to get there well
that's because I've made it so hard to
encounter these things I see to get to
the message right so that we used to
have a whole booklet that you could get
with all the messages in it how does
somebody get this message or something
it's a ref slash message slash head
slash yeah
Oh No there's nothing browsable the the
the the the documentation center has not
set up to be a browser it's set up to be
this is not obviously correct I mean we
should probably you know we should
probably make those message I mean I
think the reason we probably made it so
hard to get to is you know and only get
to on demand so to speak is because we
never finished I mean we we did a
complete pass of documenting all
messages back when twenty years ago
something in v6 so more like fifteen
years
yeah we did an update then in v6 we wit
off and then it was and I mean it's only
in the last couple of years after after
Oliver and I complained enough that taki
tools was updated to make it easy to
edit these things again because it used
to be you had to go spelunking to edit
these pages at least now there's
dedicated bones for it on the palette
but yeah it's something to be desired
concern me a lot with these messages and
the message documentation was that you
know it's so hard to not mislead people
with the message documentation oh you
got this message Oh probably what was
going on was X now you know these are
limitation that took time for there was
to construct an example that issued the
message right
that's another but I mean you know in a
sense we've been very successful with
spell checking and you know completion
and so on where it's like there is stuff
there that is totally irrelevant to you
it's spell checking to the wrong word
but you don't care so long as so long as
one of the things that said is what's
really relevant to you you're you're
good and perhaps there's a way perhaps
it was a miss thinking about message
documentation that because there were
five things that were irrelevant the
fact that there was a sixth one that's
incredibly relevant to you might be
sufficient if that makes sense other
words might my negativity about putting
in more message documentation because I
thought it was missed would mislead is
like burying the the correct leading in
that um and okay so I want to come back
again to I mean the various comments are
about expert systems messages will be
will be great and I agree that there are
probably some machine learning ish
things that we might be able to do to do
with patterns of messages and it
probably will be worth investigating I
don't really know what I'm not sure
whether we have a good training set for
that but I mean does anybody wanna okay
that idea and then I want to talk about
message buckets and then we should wrap
up soon anybody want to comment on
machine learning for message views
for example you know back in version 1
our strategy for stopping messages was
purely when you've got three of the same
things stopped but perhaps we can be
more sophisticated than that anybody
want to comment on that you know I mean
personally I don't really mind you know
the message spew is finite because it
does you know it has to have newly named
messages to keep spewing and I don't
mind the fact that if something went
horribly wrong that I see you know a
page worth of messages
well although it is sort of it you know
ideally you'd catch you know if you had
you know better error handling functions
maybe you would catch the error before
it spins out of control and throw as
hundreds of messages but yes 2/3 I mean
the the two real downsides which I don't
think you encounter that often but when
you encounter them it's really annoying
is when the the spew is so large and
continuous that it really slows down you
know the how can you get that because it
will stop off two three copies of the
same message how do you end up getting
new ones unless you're doing a separate
cell print or something like this I
don't even know what resets the counter
actually how do you get internet message
do i know i've managed to get it I know
how I've got it I've got it doing
parallel computations but how okay I
don't I think don't think the counter I
think the counter is separate for every
actually I think it's even weirder than
the counter is separate for every kernel
because I've you know run only a few
kernels and got more messages but I
think well if that's a question whether
it should be you know local to whether
we should have a global counter somehow
but but I mean how else do you get giant
message dispute I go orchids
yeah yeah I was gonna say right so it
can be if it's efficiently you know if
it's sufficiently deeply nested then
right you know when you go through and
our functions in the stack with
different messages that you can do that
right and obviously if you have a print
statement in there then oh yeah
print statements you know the echoes and
things like that your you know you asked
for it
great um but I want to come back to this
question about bucketing messages and
how we fit so I tried that we made an
attempt before I wanted to distinguish
between warnings and errors mm-hmm so
there was sort of like the super chorus
bucketing like two buckets
I predict that it failed it did as
evidenced by the fact that we aren't
using it right now yes it did it was
just
it wasn't clear-cut and I might have
persist could have persisted perhaps but
no but it's not gonna work we know it's
not gonna work because somebody's error
is somebody else's correct behavior take
log of - - is it an error that it gives
a complex number or is that correct
behavior you know to somebody well say
that's correct behavior it may not be
where these four wants but it's correct
behavior okay what do you mean by
correct I mean okay
there are things where there are
structural problems like part running
off the end of a list which which I find
to be you know it shouldn't warn about
that because we want symbolic vectors
and goddammit it should be able to deal
with that well okay so Roger that that
lead a week and we created indexed just
to get rid of part yeah I understand I
understand but but so you know an
alternative there is you know your I
want part to be generalized but then
there will be no part messages and then
people would not know that their code
was broken right but we have this you
know we have we've had this ten years
thing so so sometimes when we generalize
the language we've actually turned off
messages so that we can use some of
those you know constructs as symbolic
kind of representations that the
previously would generate messages and
we've we've turned so I know I know I
know I know it so the cost of that is
less ability to detect when code is
going out of control exactly right and
yeah and I think in the case of part
there's a good argument to be made that
that is that is too high a price right
well so the point is that in a symbolic
system you know everything can in
principle be returned and so you know
the question is but some things that we
return are we might say that's obviously
wrong but in principle anything can be
returned symbolically
I mean it's reminiscent of you know in a
type less system you don't get to do
type checking
and you know but you can have an
advisory thing that says this is
probably wrong but so my question would
be so I mean the problem is though is
that like I think especially across
different areas of functionality it's
very inconsistent
what returns on evaluated and what fails
in a different way right because for
example in lots of math code or for
example the geometry code it's extremely
common for things to return on evaluated
you know because they wants to do
symbolic things but if you're amusing
you know cloud functions or machine
learning functions or something like
that then you know then they just did
they almost never do it and I think it's
some of them this is because most of the
time when functions return on valuated
they return unevaluated because they
they you know they hope for the future
they well they either they hope for the
future but but even more generally more
practically because they're obviously
because they can tell by basically the
pattern or a few levels down from the
pattern that it will fail as opposed to
you ran a whole bunch of code and there
was a specific failure in the middle of
it right the reason for returning on
evaluated back and you know in version 1
or something the concept was if you ask
for something that we don't know what to
do we don't know how you should
interpret it 0 to the 0 let's say or
whatever it is I don't know what we do
with that but but um you know it returns
unevaluated but then the user and
principle can assign their own value to
it or can replace that with whatever
they want to replace it with so that's
the theory question is does that theory
work so I found that they're obviously
good cases where it works you do a
symbolic integral it fails you hit it
with n and that the representation is
still sitting there so it works an
alternative you know kind of evaluation
that works but from anything's and I'm
trying to remember now but I think where
I've increasingly encountered it now
over the years it's like something comes
back and there's no hope of doing
anything with it
and then I wonder what's the value of
returning on evaluate to them like if or
which for example
well I guess if if can if you can use if
like piecewise right yeah you know we
treat basically if and which is
piecewise in all the math code right by
the means do that so we don't need to do
that sure yeah I think it's not
evaluated is a really bad thing that if
we could remedy that and you know
similar case with which and switch
statements would help everyone that has
ever written code incorrectly you know
Wolfram language code incorrect this
this yeah what that line is right there
you know input 11 returning unev al you
ated this is a Brent Brent Ahmad help
anybody in 2020 at all it's still well
Brenton if I might say so your project
should solve this no I'm working okay
but but so again what would potentially
solve this is a message that is off by
default
potentially but cannibal no no but the
problem is well okay okay so it's a for
the first half of that statement the
problem is you don't know you you know
if you knew to turn on the message then
you know what the problem is and and
right but so if we had a way of bucket
catching certain categories of messages
you could do that without you know in
other words if you if you wanted if if
you care look let's say that this was a
level two warning message doesn't make
any sense we're not going to be able to
define that but let's imagine it is or
let's imagine this is a a you know a
code lint type seven message or
something it wouldn't be lint but yeah
can you can't tell it like rental well
fair enough you can't tell a
compile-time but but I mean in okay so
it's a it's a I don't know it's a a I
don't know some some programming level
something or other message and then you
say okay
I want my code to be working in this
kind of way so I'm gonna just guard
against all of those that class of
messages
the case of this is is I have a piece of
code and I'm running it and I'm getting
weird results I don't know why and the
answer is because if is returning
unevaluated because that's a weird
behavior that nobody expects right so
one solution we'd have it throw a
message but again the thing is there's a
lot of existing code that might assume
that it can be symbolic but but the
point is is that by the time that you're
doing something like guard or you're
doing something like you know changing
the message priority level or something
or turning on messages you already know
it was wrong okay I've got a different
suggestion what if there was a a what if
there was a thing called verbose sleigh
for example which you run a piece of
code and you run it verbose lis and verb
mostly switches on lots of messages that
were off by default so it's kind of like
you know - - pedantic or something with
GCC yeah and I mean that way let's say
there was a message off by default in if
you get it you've got a crazy result you
say rerun my code verbose lega and then
even these messages that would usually
be off by default show up now if we
could bucket messages in a reasonable
way something like that might be super
useful and how is that compared to
progress monitoring because I think that
a lot of things are very similar when
you want to sort of say you want to kind
of want to say what you're doing when
you say verbose Lee I think of tracing
in some way and it's sort of kind of
explaining what it does well I agree
that would be an interesting wrapper as
well I mean right now you know what
we're planning to do is to put in print
temporary type things that show up if
anything took more than a minute let's
say or more than some amount of time but
what you're saying is to have a you know
to have something that's like monitor
but let's say monitored or something
which I guess is also a thing but but
let's imagine that we could do that and
then monitored would mean always tell us
what's going on do the best you can
waste the time to start printing things
on the screen to say what's going on
well and do me like things like like
progress indicators or do you mean well
I mean look
it's giving a big manifesting so a lot
of progress indicators are somewhere in
between so there's the progress
indicator where you just have a sort of
a bar that fills wait this time but the
other things that go through stages and
they have some text it says what's going
on and it that's very much like messages
in a way yes it is except that they
disappear I mean so so another issue is
messages that evaporate messages that
evaporate by the time you've finished
and that's just a stupid idea for some
of these things I mean that that's
that's look okay so there's progress
versus messages right and so sometimes
progress has other things like for
instance like kill this you know it's
taking too long give me the best you got
so it's but the main difference between
progress and messages is progress is
something you want to evaporate when the
computation is finished
whereas messages you want to stay there
yes I think that's emits a meaningful
distinction actually right but are there
other such what we're starting to do
experiments for instance for solvers to
be able to use progress
indeed I mean but that's what we're
trying to get this whole framework for
doing progress monitoring right but I
want to come back because a bunch of
people on a live stream have been
talking about having different you know
level distinctions and messages and you
know as we've been saying we think this
is really hard to do so the question is
can we have a better idea I don't think
a linear ordering of severity of
messages is going to work so the
question is what would work is there a
way I mean or you know is it the case
that what you want is for example here's
an example you could imagine just
various groups of messages essentially
tags four types of messages where a
given message might have seven different
tags it might be oh it's a numerical
analysis message oh it's a message that
is you know not a fatal earn you know
not a fatal never a fatal thing oh it's
a message that's associated with this
class of functions you know you could
imagine tagging messages and just being
able to if we had an organized way of
representing those tags if we had a I
mean
many type types of tags is anybody gonna
remember maybe half a dozen you know
types of messages or types of tags
depends on how good the auto-completion
is if you can remember the beginning of
it but you're saying I mean you're
imagining so imagine we could bring up a
page that just says pick your tagging
right
you could you could put a thing that
says you know confirm message guard
message whatever and then the the the
autocomplete for that second argument
was a great big picker that's a great
big thing that sort of says you know
what kind of messages are you interested
in could we do that in other words we've
got the soup of all these different
messages is there a way to organize that
so that people could pick them you know
reasonably because because what we don't
want is something where you know you
have to personally go you know pick all
the pick all the pieces of fruit to get
all your messages that you want you know
there's got to be some way to say I just
want the messages in this particular
bucket right but it by the time you can
make a hundred buckets then your ever
problem right I know I know that's what
I'm saying half a dozen buckets I think
we could deal with but are there half a
dozen meaningful buckets or is it like
for example here's another is another
way of thinking about it sort of
cognitive way if any given person would
only have to remember half a dozen
buckets but if you work on different
areas of the system and different kinds
of kinds of computations like that you
know I don't it doesn't worry me too
much if the buckets that are relevant to
somebody doing I don't know a
mathematical computation we're a little
different from the buckets relevant to
somebody doing cloud computing you know
sort of systems programming in the cloud
type thing you know because those
buckets might be different I mean there
might be a bucket of messages that had
to do with sort of you know web failures
and so on that would be completely
different in character from the ones do
with numerical precision you know of
failures so my question is is there a
way to think about bucketing of messages
I mean the traditional way this is done
I mean I look I I have lived through I
could tell all kinds of stories about
earlier histories of computing where
people tried to have
severity levels velocity levels you know
ask the user type levels all kinds of
things and they're all horrible I mean
I've never seen that work has anybody
ever seen that work I mean for compilers
it's much easier and even then I would
argue Microsoft which is perhaps the
biggest now you know because the user of
this approach gets several of them wrong
well is it just wrong or is it like
they're wrong for your particular piece
of code at this particular time
well right they you know write the perd
the problem is if they declare that
something well and maybe well maybe it's
just a problem of you know they they you
know use the same number for what are
perhaps to me conceptually two different
warnings but the cases where you know
what I consider it to be the valid
warning is you know I guess the the
level three one and but then you know
the stupid one is the level two one and
there's no way to say you know level
three or lower you can all only say you
know level two are higher so there's no
way to activate the the serious you know
what I considered to be the real one
without also activating the stupid one
okay so there are a number of comments
on our live stream which I think are
interesting so there's a comment from AP
idea like in a debug message it will
include code execution times I think I
mean where this idea of an echo timing
thing is a way to start on that
okay now Ethan is saying you're
conflating use cases good I'm glad to
hear this because this is what I want is
to break these things apart simple
monitoring versus detailed logging
versus debugging versus benchmarking etc
okay can we tease those things apart I
mean it's like we have a distinction
here between progress and messages
progress evaporates messages don't
that's a meaningful distinction
now you know when you know in progress
we can have sort of logging the you know
one could imagine instead of well I
think progress is different from logging
logging is a debugging operation and you
don't want things to evaporate then okay
fair enough so that's that's what I was
calling verbose lee here is kind of a
logging function but that's the notion
there I think um and the question then
is well well I think it's not at least
the way that you the example you use
seems more like I mean a generalized my
something went wrong just give me all
the information you have about progress
and about errors fair enough okay so
that yeah you you're right you're right
so this this is what one could imagine
you know we couldn't imagine something
else which is sort of evaluate logged or
something
I know that's and one could also imagine
that that that it doesn't just produce
messages but produces an actual
computable log hence our function trace
which which you know it never has been
useful um but but again I want to come
back to this question of if we are
bucketing messages we are not going to
have a linear order because I don't
think that can work but is there useful
tagging that we can give or other tags
too mushy as well oh it's what we're
trying to design is a I mean this is
like okay
there's programs which just compute
things
there's proofs that explain why they
computed things there's kind of error
ring and messaging which again is sort
of a little bit like proofs it's kind of
explaining why things happened or it's
it's giving commentary on something you
know it's hard enough to design the
programming language let alone to design
the commenting language and the question
I guess I would have is if we were
designing a commenting language what
would we design no it's it let's say
make a computable commenting language a
commenting language where the results of
the commenting language could be fed to
a machine as opposed to just given to
humans what would it look like as I say
that was the that was the hope of trace
back in whatever 1990 or something and
it failed utterly it's way too
complicated it just it even even pruned
trace was too complicated it didn't give
one it gave one just too much micro
detail and not the big picture I mean in
a sense a commenting language is about I
want some kind of you know the
highlights the big picture what happened
how do I represent that the closest
thing I think we have to that is our is
is is assert which is a bit it's a much
smaller thing but it's but I think it's
a closest thing we have to that yes well
right but I mean that's it that's a tiny
thing I mean what I'm asking is what
people are asking for and I really think
it's an interesting thing you know
Brenton was making a big case about if
for that is you know I want to know you
know again what is that what is the
typical workflow the typical workflow is
you write a piece of code you run it it
does the wrong thing what do you do next
right if there was one thing you could
do next
like just rerun it inside verbose lis
and you would see all kinds of stuff all
kinds of commentary about what the code
was doing and all kinds of oh this is
the thing that might be wrong kind of
thing that seems like it could be very
useful
and in a sense that's an example of a 1
a 1 you know a 1 bucket I mean that's I
mean obviously we have that it's it's
sort of that's debugging you know where
you trace in detail what it does but
that wouldn't be very useful for it you
know you have to that's for a person
that wrote the program and is familiar
with it how can you make that useful and
informative for someone that doesn't do
it that's what we're studying for for
progress right but for me this is very
similar to the proofs problem I guess I
got it I understand it you made our
connection right I mean Kent is there I
mean and the proofs problem we've never
solved that is we don't know how to you
know in Wolfram Alpha when we have step
by step for example there we have a
solution to explaining why something
worked the way it worked but it's sort
of humanely created it is humanely
created yes it is created in a very
templated kind of way right whereas our
automated theorem prover absolutely
hopeless right no human understanding of
the proof so the question is is there a
way and maybe it's templated is there a
way of human explaining what happened is
there a way I mean to me I keep on
coming back to this you know messages
sort of trigger happy messages that are
off by default seems to me see we built
quite a bit of this what we've never
figured out is a good mechanism how to
publish them and at this point I think
they're part of a raft page if you read
far down in a message in a ref page you
will sometimes see that there is a
message that's off by default that you
can turn on if you're interested so for
instance for these functions that sample
functions they have a goal they want a
certain level of smoothness for the
curve or the surface and if it doesn't
achieve that because you have a given a
trésor give a message it couldn't
achieve the ACT Bend or whatever I can't
remember them now it was that Bend it's
a very old message yes yeah and I don't
think anybody uses it because it's off
by default and
right but that's imagining that's off by
default tonight and you can get more
information if you turn it on but so
let's imagine that verbose lis simply
turned on every message then that curve
that you've got I mean again I don't
know if that's right but you know you
could say put in more messages you might
need to warn people about this you know
you might need to warn them that a
computing log of a negative number or
you might say no nobody needs to be
warned about that and you know
ultimately people could be warned about
everything you know you're subtracting
numbers and you're getting zero and then
you're multiplying zero but you know for
example a classic example is zero times
X gives zero right you know that can
lead to crazy stuff going on but it will
be completely nuts to have a message in
general for that case but on the other
hand you might want a message that's off
by default for that case I think
something very useful could be that once
you get the message there is a way to
automatically go to the code that meets
that list I know I was talking about
that or turn off this message forever
well we have a mechanism for that we
have a mechanism by call oh yeah um but
I mean this question about jumping to
where the message happened in the code
that's not always well-defined that code
might have not been there may be no
lexical version there may be no static
version of that code that ever existed
brenton do you have any comments about
going to the source of the message in
the actual code I mean my my parser
would you know do that 20 times before a
breakfast if we you know who we wired it
up to the kernel I mean you're obviously
we could you know generate you can put a
string into two expression and you know
the messages that come out of that
wouldn't have a you know a source of
line and column information and that's
fine but you know we're talking about
the 99% of okay no I know I know source
location so at runtime a message is
generated are you capable of going into
your abstract syntax tree or whatever it
is and finding the code that generated
that mess
well yeah yeah I mean just um you know
in theory wiring stuff up to the current
I mean the colonel could do this now if
you flip the right switches so that it
when you read in a package it remembers
you know all of the source information
you know if you if you turn on the right
state and you know the right debug mode
I know but equation is in the kernel
somewhere right but that's the debugger
which runs the code much slower right um
yeah slower and more memory and you know
everybody so so that's why what I'm what
I'm saying is if we could have something
a rapper like verbose Lee or whatever it
is that is easy to use that just says
look I want to run this more carefully
you know I ran it did the wrong thing
let me run it more carefully well but
the source has already been read in
presumably at that point though if you
haven't yeah by the time your your note
you oh I want to do that wrapping with
verbosely now you've already read in
whatever package come well that's a
question I mean that's an engineering
question I don't know the answer to I
mean when the debugger was built it it
just has a completely different data
structure but maybe there is some kind
of you know we caching sort of attached
thing that isn't actually part of the
main data structure that you could use
to find that information I mean yeah if
the information is there yeah yeah yeah
yeah no I mean at the time of reading in
you could for example let let me give an
example you could fork off something
that asynchronously reads the thing with
the tagging information and sticks that
as a thing based on hashes that will say
you know if you ever need this it's
hanging out there I don't know I mean
that that seems like a lot of work for
not a lot of I mean I don't know what
asynchronously means and I don't know
what I mean I'm just saying we can't
slow down the reading of a package every
single time for the point zero zero one
percent of times that people want to run
it for mostly like no no yeah so you
know you you it it just comes along for
the ride every single time yeah
all packaged is you know at some point
in time in the future when you read in a
package its source information will be
available but that's only okay if it's
like only a 1% slowdown or something
it's not okay if it's a 20% slowdown
well I'm saying with the yeah I mean
just hold on you know like the parsing
technology that the kernels using is you
know older than the kernel itself and
I'm saying I mean it would require
engineering obviously but we don't we
don't even we don't need a slowdown in
reality even with you know it's putting
a little bit of TLC into the parsing
technology would all right okay fine so
you say it up so much that we don't care
about the fact that we're slowing it
down slightly for restoring that it's
extra information but buffer which work
a little bit like that
um but imagine that you could take a
proof and automatically generate text
from it that is an attempt to explain
that proof I mean I think I think in the
current state of technology that will be
a total failure but that's the kind of
thing that we would like to have I think
whereas people who are asking for
let's see commenting language create
defined assumptions based on what occurs
at runtime
to find something up cause further
errors yeah I mean I think the calculus
of errors is really complicated because
in a sense you know it's like saying how
do you validate a piece of code well
what's the code supposed to do
well the code says what the code is
supposed to do oh so then we need to
rewrite the code in a different
validation language to explain what the
code is supposed to do or we give
certain asserts for what the code is
supposed to do but so what's the way to
think about again I'm Roger or anybody
at Christopher anybody else so it's sort
of a way to think about conceptually I
think I mean I think we empirically we
discover that code is almost impossible
to understand if you have no other
information unless it was written to be
understandable yeah we have plenty of
legacy code you know since we have many
people that worked over the years and
some of them it's just easier to throw
away and start over than trying to even
understand it maybe that's not solving
this problem I mean this problem is
using written code but okay so you know
we have several levels here so first
point people usually augment their code
if they want to prove properties about
their code or they want to tell other
stories about it they think you're
basically gonna have to mark up your
code with more information and and one
thing that you can mark it up with is
it's like for proving things or
invariants
for instance properties that hold it you
see in a sense Christopher's idea here
with the confirm and close you know God
contain that is a form of markup for
code it is and in a sense it's very it's
very pragmatic markup it's not markup
that's just asserting things it's it's
saying what to do hmm
I know so one question would be with
that conceptual idea is there I mean in
a sense that idea of segues into the
message markup idea I see I don't know
there's God there's got to be a way we
have information in these messages we
have information and messages that we
are as yet unborn messages that haven't
been created or not being generated by
default we have sort of meta information
about what the code is doing based on
its message trace so to speak it's it's
Engram of message
it's some information about what the
code is doing particularly if the code
is doing the wrong thing so question is
how do we best use that but we've got
this this sort of zoo of messages
because right now you know like for
example we use very little meta
information about our code execution so
for example you know as code executes
the stack is getting bigger smaller
whatever else it realistically nobody is
writing code that is asking you know
admire the behavior of the stack
conclude what's going on based on that I
mean at the beginning of less you're
teaching your first programming class
hmm well right I mean and don't talk to
me I was just studying transfinite
numbers and Combinator's and looking at
um you know this question about the
anyway never mind but but um you know
Brenton's project to do with you know
using machine learning and other methods
on code analysis is the static version
of this that is given the code
understand your code statically and make
suggestions about it but what we're
asking for here is a dynamic version so
I think that that's that static analysis
when you're not using super-expensive
they're improving capabilities has been
immensely successful in practice yeah
well I know and I think brenton is is
going to unroll for us in the next
version with essentially spell checking
like things for code is going to be
really really useful I mean just like
syntax coloring just like function
you know Auto completion or all those
kinds of things another thing like that
it has a you know I think the plan is to
have a little bit of machine learning in
there for guessing I don't know maybe
Brenton can say what some examples of
that are um but um you know I predict
this is going to be very very useful and
and the fact that it is heuristic is not
that nobody's gonna but be bothered by
that I mean worst case is making in
order suggestion that isn't the right
suggestion so just ignore it I mean
there's a ton of other static analyzers
that are basically lightweight theorem
provers but they're so lightweight that
they scale they don't bog down like
theorem provers - yeah and they still
find a ton of practical things well I
guess that that's the future of
Brandon's project is to expand you know
through perhaps through the compiler
technology and other things expand the
level of analysis that we can do yeah go
ahead
no no I mean just yeah that there's a
big road map yeah so I will have to
leave in just a couple of minutes but
you know the closest thing to dynamic
analysis that I'm aware of are things
like the address sanitizer and the
undefined behavior sanitizer and they
you know first of all they're super
focused they increase the compile times
by sometimes in order of magnitude what
are you talking about
there are tools for C and C++ code so
the address sanitizer checks for all
sorts of you know use after three
mismatched things and the undefined
behavior looks for when you're relying
you know when you're right wrote code
that doesn't actually conform to the
standard and therefore you know an
optimizer may decide to change its
behavior and break your code and I mean
and they're useful they're certainly the
address sanitizer is very useful the
undefined behavior one is a bit more
questionable but you know they come at
great cost and like and this is you know
compiling specific instrumentation into
the code it's hard to see how something
like that can be turned on but the
vagueness that does those kinds of are
there all kinds of other things to look
for buffer overruns and counter overruns
and dos but the thing is that those
things let's say that you cut down the
number of errors that you do as a user
by one set of tools 90% you had the next
bucket you hit 90% of that
very soon your productivity goes up you
don't have this right no and that's what
we've already seen with syntax coloring
we'll see it with with Brent and stuff
etc etc and I think with you know the
goal
I mean look that the the main point of
this meeting was discussing you know
confirmed in close or whatever it's
going to be called and I think the
general you know it sounds like people
think this is a good direction but I
think it's important to go inventory in
more detail what some of the cases are
but one of the pieces of that is a
confirmed message or whatever it's
called and then the question is how do
we do that
right can we do that in a meaningful way
where we have you know something which
says I just don't know how I don't know
how to do that I mean I don't know how
to how to characterize types of messages
that's what we can I think the first
step you don't I mean so you have
confirmed message which is basically
your assertion as a programmer that I
expect this block of code to not issue
any messages and as soon as it does I
need to take action okay but but you see
which then will also you know sort of
help with the message few sorts of
things okay but but I push back on that
let's say that you're writing some very
critical piece of code and you want to
say if you know and you want to be very
kind of you know trigger-happy about it
that is if anything goes even possibly
conceivably wrong just fail right you
say gosh I wish you'd given me a message
that you just multiplied by zero to get
zero or something but you didn't there
was no message because we didn't happen
to have a message you know on off
whatever right so you're saying messages
are little flags that go up that say
something might have gone wrong here and
the question is how how piss Lickety how
pedantic do you want to be about looking
for those messages and sometimes
depending on the use case for your code
you might want to say I mean look
depends what the thing is doing you know
there are situations where the thing is
flying a plane and the plane has to keep
flying and the fact that it generated a
message well sorry but but you know or
or at some point it says you know beep
beep beep human has to take over right
but you have to those kinds of things
are you know you've got to be able to
determine what level of you know you
it's gonna make you feel better there
are problems so for power systems they
suffer message Cascades that people are
men not able to handle that happened in
Chernobyl for instance yeah you know so
empower you know like electrical power
so they're various places where those
things are monitored but often they're
Cascades they're things that cause us
something else to fail causes something
else to fail and there are huge Cascades
and that's been very big focus but those
are very much safety kind of important
but so is that I mean you know Chernobyl
is a famous story but I mean is is there
any reasonable way to think about that I
mean I I know that people in it's like a
warning light came on you know is yeah
oh I'll have to dig in but I think that
what they basically tried to do is to
construct that bigger higher level
picture what the heck is going on even
though there's cascades of messages and
they built basically kind of like a
graph more than one level up so you can
see the forest in spite of all the trees
ok so what that is doing is what we were
saying we didn't know how to do which is
like proof summarization yes effectively
that's what it doing so so ok so that's
a question given a spew of messages
given a giant cascade of messages can
you make a higher level conclusion from
it yeah so that's what's been put
resources into death area so for us I'm
not sure how useful that is because the
most important thing for us is well what
is the important thing the important
thing is your code has a bug go fix it
you know your code there's something you
didn't think about in your code you can
change your code to fix that
another possibility is something kind of
generally unexpected happened and can
you explain roughly what happened
I think that's less useful it's kinda
like interpreting black box data when
plane crashes all the information is
there but it still takes people months
to figure it out yes yes I mean well
it's like what does the what does the
accident report ultimately say and it
doesn't you know have all the micro
details probably of maybe they do
actually and in them but but no but I
think that the question is for us okay
the other thing so if you want to build
sort of reliable code to stress it
beforehand and so can one build tools
that makes it easier to stress it
beforehand so it's not so labor
intensive for instance to do that so one
tool that I use for developing that my
parser has been a fuzz testing is a big
tool for stressing you know beforehand
where your tool
it feeds whatever you're working on
random input to see if it crashes and
stuff like that but crucially it's not
just purely random and put it's working
with instrumented code so that the you
know it can see what pads your code
takes depending on the input and it you
know it chooses the random input in ways
that tries to cheat you know take
different paths and fuzz testing tools
like AFL and Lib buzzer and all these
things are immense like so incredibly
useful for testing
you know parsers but also you know image
anything to do with file format you know
things that just take seemingly
arbitrary you know input so incredibly
useful but that's a different category
of discussion is automated testing and
what we can do for for you know because
users unfortunately rarely produce tests
for code and you know we've got a desire
but that's why I brought this up is
there a way to I mean so first of all we
have made some things easier we dosed
notebook testing you know it's an
interesting idea Brenton I mean you know
and a fuzz testing function might be an
interesting idea that is you you know
that you've got F of seven okay and and
you use that as one example you know can
you generate fuzz around that based on
looking at the code and and looking at
input I don't know whether that makes
any sense but let's say in this this
touches on symbolic execution and other
more complicated topics but you could do
something really basic if you are okay
with running with instrumented code you
know if you if you loaded a package that
you're working on in some special way
that it instruments all of your code you
know everything around if statements and
all the branding that could take then
you know everything becomes a lot easier
I mean you know obviously still worked
well but so let me let me point out
something that's an issue there let's
say you've instrumented your code you
get the logging data from the
instrumented code the problem is and
that was the problem of trace back in
1990 it generates wonderful logging data
it's just incomprehensible oh yeah no I
don't think a human would ever see
anything that but and what does that
machine look for what is the Machine
looking for in those log files or logs
what is it looking for what does it
trigger on what does it how does it tell
the story based on that well it knows
you know depending on an if statement
you know if it took one branch it can
kind of do it has you know very you know
but you can apply backwards you type of
reasoning to you know what what had to
have happened to take this branch and so
you know do the opposite whatever that
condition is obviously you have to be
specific you know to take the other
branch and we're talking about symbolic
execution and this is well explored and
you know can be talked about but a human
would never see any of this going on the
human sees you know when something fails
or crashes what that input was and
usually the human you know the buzz
testing tool did you know a hundred
thousand man hours worth of work to
generate one crash you know of some with
some in
and the human can usually just see what
that single input was and almost know
immediately what the problem is and so
you know that's it's just a great kind
of balance between you know you do all
the work over here but only tell me at
the very end what the input was because
that's really all that I care about I
can step through later with you know
that input and reconstruct you know
whatever that holds no I think it's
interesting idea somebody should try and
make a sort of candidate top-level fuzz
testing thing hey listen let's just make
a note of few things on the legs anyway
and that's exactly ho of verification of
discrete systems work but you what you
generate is one trace or failure trace
and those might be very deep which means
that you can't even test your way to
them because it's just way too expensive
to even get to that level of coverage
testing wise so this is for high
reliability kinds of systems there's
people on our live stream I'm talking
about quick check I don't know what it
is but this seems to be it's page just
people know about this oh I see I see
okay so this is this is a generator of
tests
this would be yet another avenue to take
y'all right I mean sideways
justifications and generating random
input based on type specification in
some sense yeah so random generators of
more kinds it's generally useful in this
context and we have rastelli producing
more of them I you know in the world
that I always bring this up and just
because I'm silly but but in in the
world of of ancient things SMP had a
random expression generator Oh drat
don't have it but um you know that was
an idea in back in time of SMP I had a
mechanism for generating um you know
random expressions this leg was that
like random or it was it was called was
called Rex the random you know SMP had
short function names another bad idea
but it was it was them I have to just
bring up its documentation I wish I
could actually run it why can't I run it
so maybe you don't have a be backs
machine no no I have I have a way to do
this it'll run up some P dot app here we
go see Dada clock gained what on earth
is this I don't even know what this
check and reset the date it might be off
by 50 years or so 40 years Oh No
checking oh oh isn't it it's something
Wow okay something very trivial on your
on your you oh it would ran on bsd unix
that's almost modern i think it's i
think it's nothing
no-no-no SW and then just press ENTER
okay ah drat 4.3 bsd unix
is that like sun sun OS in the 80s or
something that's well it says 1987 here
friday 1907 okay i remember right this
is running in like multiple levels of VN
i think i think it's honest-to-goodness
Berkeley Berkeley UNIX because yeah the
Sun was based on four point X but it you
know it would identify itself as Sun OS
oh okay alright and now that now that
I'm challenged here I'm gonna see if I
can actually run this hold on one second
look up here we go ah there we go that's
the answer there we go just used route
you have new mail from 1986 I hate to
even imagine what that could possibly be
but anyway might be your printer daemon
complaining about that can't connect to
the printer look at this so this record
you also have a wargames
but the thing is even if interesting as
that is it's useless I mean it's right
that's what I was gonna say it's
absolutely useless the question is how
to make this useful so that there's a
random oh look at that yeah there was
some grammar to help it along exactly
but what we often need sort of
constraints and other levels into
grammar too it's not pure grammar tutor
I'm saying because there's that they're
sort of they're often semantic
constraints to to be able to feed this
function or whatever it is right you
know like being positive semi-definite
is not a grammar property
yeah I mean people okay so that various
comments on our livestream I just want
to just want to highlight some of these
so this idea of a framework for
generating tests clearly a useful thing
and we should explore that some more and
this random expression based on grammars
is an interesting direction but we can
probably do things I mean you know
expression grammars is not something
we've particularly been concerned about
we've mostly been concerned about
computing things from expressions rather
than characterizing well I guess I guess
we have patterns which are expression
grammars in some sense um and now we
have types for the compiler which is
also something along the same lines
um hey on our live stream people are
even is commenting on extending message
beyond strings heck yes we need that and
I you know I don't think people in this
maybe somebody in this meeting can
comment on that why it's been so hard to
extend message to work for things other
than strings in which since what other
things having the payload for a message
function : : thing
you mean message name yes message name
the value of message name not being well
for one thing everything in it you know
the hold all the code assumes it's a
string I mean I'm not sure exactly how
hard but you'd need somebody to spend
however long doing it I'm not sure it's
a question of adding another level of
indirection I mean we could they're
engineering solutions I can imagine that
would just add another level of
indirection I mean we already have
message bah-bah-bah : : language for
example and you know I could imagine
adding something you know as a way to do
the engineering I could imagine I could
imagine various kinds of ways to do the
engineering but mm-hmm
but I mean I know that's an issue and
know this is when we're not talking
about making the second argument a
message name not a string we're talking
about the actual message that comes back
the the template for the message being
not a string so that you could actually
have a message that has a you know a
table or a graphic in it which you can
only do by include
doing it as you know through string
templates um let's let's see um yeah so
they're concerns that the existing
testing framework isn't good enough we
agree I mean she testing for a movie
come back as a message I will show you a
movie there it is well yes just wait for
some stuff happening in Wolfram Alpha
along those lines
um let's see the yeah so someone's
commenting on here about the the testing
framework and an exception handling
framework yeah the whole subject of this
meeting was about exception handling um
the let's see um but most they should be
called loud since we already have quiet
interesting there's one commenter and in
fact you can't sort of do that already
right because you can there's a third
argument of quiet which is too unquiet
so you can sort of unquiet everything if
you really want to mmm and there are
questions about um the comment here
about community-driven error feedback
system um yeah I mean I'm not quite sure
what that really is I mean I think you
know there are things we know for
example in the elementary introduction
to orphan language book which has an
online auto graded code system we do
know I Rick here I think would be able
to comment on that but I mean we do know
a lot of stuff about bad code that has
been entered in that is that a fair
statement Rick yeah I mean we have the
data to figure out the bad stuff people
do right but I mean that the point there
is that is a data set of this is a piece
of semantics you know this is something
that was semantically aimed for this is
what actually happened and that's an
interesting data set because it tells us
the types of errors people make and we
look to you know we haven't looked so
much of that we looked at some stuff to
do with the problem generator for math
problems I guess we haven't have we look
to
code code errors there and because
that's an interesting question it's what
I mean another famous example of how not
to handle error messages and we should
wrap up in a mom of I have to show you
this because it's my one of my favorite
design mistake stories um is see this is
um SMP documentation and I can show you
the category and the category of
absolute of a thing not to do okay this
is that this is one of those things not
to do stories at the end here um I'll
come on I have to show you this this is
well this stuff is okay this was this
was stuff that we finally have got in
more from language we've got oh except
we don't have that we don't have ask
your large product signs we've never had
a product sign in ASCII art um and uh
see how I get this to go back oh gosh um
you
oh here we go
this someplace here where was this Isis
probably full of weird stuff but I was
it this probably has funny stuff in it
from from implementation of but what I'm
looking for is a page that was called um
I was a page called called things that
can go wrong
basically yeah that might be it no you
see that was that was the reporter of a
suspected error that the fascinating
thing was I had a page in the
documentation which was basically a
things that could go wrong and that page
people were very confused about whether
that page was um is this PDF so
unbelievably slow is there a way to get
it to display thumbnails um somebody
know how this works
no but not in Chrome
Ropin it in oh I see what you're saying
if I opened it in a an actual PDF reader
I would get this to work I don't know I
but it's been me I mean I was showing
but it it's quite an interesting thing
because it had a list of of possible
things that people could do wrong and
that was the worst thing you can
possibly document because people simply
remembered the things that they could do
wrong in other words they didn't
remember the right way to do it they
remembered the possible error
mm-hmm right it's like one of our
friends complaints that whenever she
tells her husband to go to the store and
he can buy everything except the
pumpernickel bread
guess which bread right minutes it's a
um it's I think it's one of those
cognitive things almost I'm frustrated
I've got to find this I'm almost sure um
that's um nope come on I gotta go
is this a tear-off thing or is this was
too rough no this was tear off back in
in the day I remember tear ass oh well I
seem to have lost this but no case um um
just I wonder what I would have called
it potential oh well that was fun I
noticed an acknowledgment to rub pike
there of talking of programming
languages um who was the person who
persuaded me that C was the language of
the future is the author of go for
people who know programming language
history um okay well I'm not finding
this but oh here we go there we go I
finally found it just as I was about to
wrap up here some common difficulties
this was such a profoundly bad idea
because oh this is number one was a
system a fine projection that's a
function return' done simplified and
evaluated when evaluation is expected
and um a strange result involving
unexpected objects is obtained says you
probably know we have an analogue of
this today we call that possible issues
on the reference pages we do yes we do
but for some reason that hasn't caused
the same problem now but we always the
point is that we're trying to sort of
either explain that or so how to solve
it if you have it yes right right
I mean well this is doing that too but
the problem with this was it was it
became kind of a short summary of 10
things you need to know and the 10
things you need to know here ended up
being things that are you know things
that you got wrong right anyway okay so
listen just summarizing this meeting
it's it sounds like Christopher should
go and try and learn about anybody does
anybody here have particular error
handling code or ideas that um that
Christopher should make sure to
inventory like particularly anybody who
has a framework with actual functions
that do error handling
that's a deafening silence okay but so
there are can
which have been discussed in this
meeting for how to do the throw catch or
a handling and so on does anybody use
anything other than throw and catch as
their way of doing production error
handling a handler block for messages
sometimes a nice therefore things that's
related okay what is a handler block
what is that so you can basically pass a
function for when a message would print
like do something with it is that a
built-in function it's it's internal
it's it's an internal function basically
it's it's a handle for various types of
events of which one is messages okay
that sounds like another thing
Christopher should know about if he
doesn't already do know about
that's how for example know there's a
function that that's like guard message
in this yeah which is the general
utility is with message handler which I
think just calls this okay all right all
right
might be nice if we had some internal
documentation about about handler block
well let's hope we can expose what's
relevant from it a top level all right
well good thanks everybody
and somebody's suggesting looking at F
sharp Sarah handling don't know anything
about it but um maybe um yeah I know
that Microsoft has done a lot of work on
sort of programming language analysis um
the yeah okay well good thanks everybody
and thanks to folks on the livestream
lots of interesting and good comments
here much appreciated
see y'all soon